nosotros empezamos con una onda cuadrada
del periodo 2 y verdad y nos preguntamos
si podemos representarla como una serie
con una suma infinita de senos y cosenos
con ciertos pesos y partiendo de esta
idea
digamos pudimos hallar expresiones
verdad para tanto el coeficiente a 0 a n
que son los que acompañan a las
funciones coseno y vene que son los
coeficientes que acompañan a las
funciones seno verdad de hecho sabemos
que hacer o es tres medios para el caso
de la onda cuadrada a n todos tienen que
valer 0 verdad y por lo tanto no van a
aparecer funciones coseno en nuestro
desarrollo en serie de furia y bueno bn
que son los que tienen la expresión un
poquito más complicada en el caso en el
que en esta vale 0 y en el caso impar
vale 6 entre n pitt muy bien entonces
vemos que no tenemos cosenos verdad sólo
nos queda la constante
los términos impares para seno verdad
entonces esto tiene sentido porque la
función seno más o menos se ve vamos a
ponerlo aquí verdad la función seno más
o menos se ve de esta forma digamos y
por aquí anda el 1 más o menos aquí
alcanzamos el 1 en pick up's vamos a
hacerlo bien aquí tenemos más o menos
una representación de la función seno
verdad más o menos estoy tratando de
hacerlo lo mejor que se puede
ok más o menos así se ve la función seno
y por eso es que tendríamos una buena
aproximación pensando como funciones
seno verdad y si nosotros observamos la
función coseno ésta empieza más o menos
de en uno más o menos por aquí vale cero
en medios verdad y vuelve a bueno vale
ahora menos uno en pi luego sube a cero
en tres y medios y vuelve al valor uno
cuando estamos en dos para más o menos
este es un esbozo de la función coseno y
podemos ver
está desfasada con respecto a nuestra
onda cuadrada y en realidad la fase de
la función se no coincide mucho mejor
con la onda cuadrada verdad entonces de
ahí podemos ver que las funciones que no
estarán en fase con la onda cuadrada
mientras que los cosenos no tanto verdad
y por eso podríamos pensar
intuitivamente que los cosenos no van a
aparecer ahora con base en los valores
de a 0 a n y bn como veríamos está
digamos estas aproximaciones en series
de furia y verdad de hecho podemos
nosotros graficar las aproximaciones
verdad y esto lo puedes hacer incluso en
google
tú puedes poner las funciones en google
peter y te las va graficando entonces
por ejemplo esta primera imagen esta que
tenemos aquí es justamente la gráfica de
tres medios + 6 / bi xenón dt es
justamente esta de aquí muy bien esta de
aquí entonces podemos podemos incluso
poner nuestro
digamos aquí nuestra onda cuadrada más o
menos se verá si la onda cuadrada llega
a tres punto y cachito verdad y luego
vale cero y luego hasta acá vale cero
más o menos así se estaría viendo
nuestra onda cuadrada muy bien entonces
podemos ver incluso que los primeros dos
términos si son una muy buena
aproximación de nuestra onda cuadrada
verdad la siguiente imagen la que tengo
aquí abajo sería tomándonos un término
más en este en este desarrollo en serie
de furia sería tomándonos estos tres y
podemos ver que cada vez se va
apareciendo más a nuestra onda cuadrada
si tomamos otro término que sería 6
entre 5 y seno de 5 t y con los otros
sumandos por supuesto tenemos una mejor
aproximación a la onda cuadrada y
podríamos tomar otro término más que
sería 6 sobre 7 pi seno de 7 pi verdad
el siguiente término y al sumar con
todos los anteriores nos da una mejor
aproximación entonces podemos ver que
esto
funciona muy muy bien y esto es algo
grandioso sobre todo si te pones a
pensar que todo esto sale de las
matemáticas